your character arrived in yharnam from a
faraway land seeking a cure for some
unnamed illness you sign a contract take
blood and become a hunter of the drink
tasked with ending the spreading scourge
of beasts like many hunters before you
your consciousness is now bound to the
hunter's dream and you are able to
project yourself into the waking world
of yharnam at the end of the game the
nameless moon presence descends this is
a great one an elder being that beckoned
to the hunters and conceived the
hunter's dream and you're here now
asking why well let me tell you the
story up until this point it all began
in the tombs below yharnam once what we
now call chalice dungeons contained an
entire civilization it consisted of the
Tamarians and the great ones the tomb
Aryans were a humanoid race but the
great ones were far from it each great
one is bizarre unique and trying to pin
down their motivations as a species or
individually is fairly futile the only
thing that's clear about them is this
the great ones like any other race want
to reproduce but for them it's difficult
each great one appears to be truly
unique and since that makes mating
impossible they impregnate their
subjects instead the ring of betrothal
states that in the age of the great ones
certain tomb Aryans were permitted to
bear a special child
this union was a blood contract our
first reference to the blood of the
great ones
most of these births failed but some
didn't
at some point the great ones ascended we
know this because there are multiple
references to some great ones being left
behind the great ones moved on to the
nightmare realm and the two Marian's
were left alone destined to watch over
the physical remains of the slumbering
great ones in time the Tamarian
civilization fell to the plague of
beasts perhaps it was something in the
blood eventually a group of Bergen worth
scholars stumbled upon this place and
the events of blood-borne were set into
motion the scholars discovered the old
blood of the great ones a miraculous
substance that made their dream of
evolution a reality the school of Bergen
worth was headed by Master Willem an
ambitious yet cautious man
Willem desired to ascend to a higher
plane of existence and believed that the
knowledge of the great ones would lead
him there on the other hand one of
Williams associates Lawrence believed
that mankind could ascend through use of
the old blood the blood of the great
ones
Lawrence seems headstrong and rash where
Willem advised caution when we inspect
the skull after defeating vodka Amelia
this is the conflict we see no but you
will never listen I tell you I will not
forget our adage Lawrence tells Willem
he will always fear the old blood yet he
goes on to found the healing church a
faith built upon the miraculous old
blood meanwhile Willem remains behind at
Bergen worth and decides to pursue
alternate methods to ascension Lawrence
and his church was central to the power
in yharnam perhaps they even built the
place blood ministers doled out the
miraculous healing blood to the populace
and the city evolved to reflect that
people came from far and wide just like
you did for the chance to be healed the
Anna mites whose doors you knock on are
quite arrogant and proud and dislike
outsiders however after the old blood
was introduced into the populace people
began turning into beasts
right there not an inch
in response the church founded the
hunters workshop with German at its head
Germans methods defined beasts hunting
he abandoned the notion of armor and
dressed instead for speed and agility
with a firearm in one hand and adaptable
melee weapon in the other the forces of
the workshop became the city's primary
defense against the beastly threat
perhaps the workshop was even a secret
organization for item descriptions note
that they worked under the cover of
night and the location of the workshop
was certainly difficult to find in time
the workshop would be abandoned in
favour of the black and white church
hunters perhaps Gorman's workshop failed
in keeping the scourge a secret perhaps
the church required a more intimidating
approach whatever the case the hunters
were fighting for something and it
wasn't just to keep the populace safe
turns out the hunters workshop was just
one of three branches of the church the
others were the choir and Michael Ash's
school of mensis the choir existed to
continue the work that began at Bergen
worth namely the pursuit of insight by
way of communion with the great ones the
choirs work eventually led them to an
audience with a brightest a left behind
great one the school of mensis was as
the name implies devoted to research and
learning and while item descriptions
state that menses was allied with the
healing church in our adventures it
becomes clear that the school is
responsible for most of the problems in
this world in blood-borne it's difficult
to point to a main antagonist but if I
had to I'd point to Mikkel ash who was
the head over the school of mensis
somehow Mukesh got his hands on the
umbilical cord of a great one these
cords are very important
for simplicity's sake think of these
umbilical cords as powerful relics that
enable contact with the great ones there
are three of these umbilical cords in
game and they are used by three of the
main characters one cord was found by
Mikkel ash head of the school of mensis
one cord is held by willem back in
Bergen Worth and another cord went to
gurmann of the hunters workshop Mikkel
ash used his cord to perform a great
ritual it ripped a lecture hall of
mensis into the Nightmare Realm so that
they could be granted audience with a
being named Mogo it is believed that
Mogo is the child of a great one birthed
through yharnam the two Marian Queen
there is little known about his power
his origins or his significance so just
know for now that mensis wanted audience
with Mogo but that this audience came at
a great cost a note in the village reads
the menses ritual must be stopped
lest we all become beasts Willem used
his cord to and I quote elevate his
being and thoughts to those of a great
one by lining his brain with eyes in the
lake below him we come across rom the
vacuous spider many descriptions in game
tell us that this spider hides all
manner of rituals in particular though
it seems that the spider is holding back
the effects of the menses ritual when
rom is gone a blood moon descends
blurring the line between beast and man
after this event we find the path -
yah-ha ghoul open so our character can
go through and silence the harrowing
cries of mergo the infant great one the
third umbilical cord found its way into
ger man's hands after his hunter's
workshop disbanded Herman was alone and
unimportant his only companion was this
doll which he appears to have crafted
with love and care
perhaps this dolls creator had wished
for such a friend Albee it in vain his
cord reads the great ones that inhabit
the nightmare are sympathetic in spirit
and often answer when called upon this
third chord summoned the moon presents a
great one which beckoned the hunters and
conceived the hunter's dream
Germann got what he wanted a companion
and a purpose but he becomes a puppet
endlessly finding and guiding hunters
through the dream and out into the world
assumedly under the influences and
desires of the moon presence so to recap
Michael ash whose character is ever
ambitious to ascend and become a great
one used his cord to establish contact
he sacrificed his school of mensis and
brought the consequences of that contact
upon the world willem ever cautious used
his cord and rome to mask the effects of
that ritual and Gherman lonely and
lacking purpose became a puppet to
another great one named the moon
presence he guides hunters through this
dream and out into a few select
locations the hunter's dream ends when
you successfully hunt down mojo and his
nightmare of menses suggesting that
menses was the root of the scourge of
beasts and perhaps that the moon
presence wanted the child of another
great one dead when you silenced mojo he
returned to the workshop on fire the
dreams purpose is fulfilled you
approached gurmann host of this hunter's
dream and he tells you that he has the
power to free you if you choose this
option you are unbound from the dream
you lived through the hunt and saw the
sunrise over yharnam if you reject
Kerman the moon presents decides it
needs another host for its dream you you
become captivated by the moon presence
and pledge to watch over the hunter's
dream but there is a third option
ascension when the conditions are right
for a great one to be born the mother
and child can be harvested for an
umbilical cord but all great ones lose
their children and yearn for a surrogate
child instead a replacement micolash
willem gurmann they all found umbilical
cords somewhere in the past and used
them for their own needs but ultimately
each of them was unsuccessful in the
contact that they had with the great
ones
however the notes of the bergen Worth
scholars contain this information 3/3
courts hunt the great ones hunt the
great ones if you consume three cords
you can resist becoming the moon
presences captive instead you hunt the
moon presence and afterward you become
an infant great one living inside the
dream the moon presents conceived you
managed to ascend there's no one else
before you did and you will lift
humanity into its next childhood